well there's a stiff competition going
on right now for the title of the biden
regime's most stupid and most
self-defeating policy was it saying to
the taliban you know what we don't need
to control all of kabul we just keep the
airport you take the rest was it paying
people to stay home and then wondering
why businesses can't find workers and
the jobs reports get worse and worse
was it defunding the police and seeing
violent crime rise out of control
unleashing crazy government spending and
seeing inflation rise out of control
opening the southern border and seeing
illegal immigration rise out of control
they're all strong contenders
but tonight i'm going to make a case
that their most stupid and most
self-defeating policy is biden's war on
energy to be fair he did warn us
we are going to get rid of fossil fuels
he wasn't kidding as soon as he got into
office biden stopped new oil and gas
leases on public lands cancelled the
keystone pipeline and announced the
reimposition of the red tape that
handcuffed our energy supplies before
trump got rid of it they keep talking
about wind power it doesn't help much if
you have a quote windless summer like
they just had in the uk
they want solar power even though it
can't be economically stored and the
panels are made with carbon and slave
labor from china
they're shutting down nuclear power
which is the most reliable carbon-free
source of energy we've got what's the
entirely predictable result if you wage
war on energy the price goes up so now
we have gas prices at a seven year high
energy cost pushing up overall inflation
and heating costs this winter predicted
to jump as much as 54
so what are the geniuses in the biden
regime doing about this crisis they
created in their giant spending bill
they want to take more money from
american workers and give it in
subsidies to rich democrats in
california to buy more teslas so they
can virtually signal about how green
they are except as a result of the
democrats clamp down on oil and gas we
are now importing more oil from saudi
arabia and most insane of all
they're trying to fill the energy gap
they created in the name of fighting
climate change by begging opec to pump
more oil so they're against energy jobs
in this country but in favor of them in
other countries they want us to be more
reliant on energy that's less reliable
and on dictators and despots including
vladimir putin i thought they hated him
all the while increasing fuel prices and
carbon emissions can anyone make sense
of this
let's see if larry kudlow can he is of
course the host of kudlow on the fox
business network and he joins us now all
right larry what is this about
by the way it's a it's a real horse race
on which is the dumbest policy i mean i
this thing's gonna go on and on
it's it's a stock looking for a bottom
in the charts but look there is because
of the biden policies you were
discussing
there is now a shortage of fossil fuels
there's a shortage here in the u.s but
that shortage is global and i'll give
you uh probably the base case here
we were the swing producers under trump
we were the swing producers of the u.s
of oil
and
unfortunately now under biden
we've no longer the swing producer the
saudis and opec pluses so we were
pumping out 13 million barrels per day
pre-pandemic
and since the pandemic or as we've
recovered it has dropped to 11 million
barrels a day despite the increase in
economic demands there has been no
increase in the supply of oil
the same is true for natural gas uh
look the oil price tonight tonight is
trading at eighty three dollars and five
cents i checked before i came on that's
double where it was roughly a year ago
natural gas is five and a quarter uh
that's almost a double from where it was
a year ago and gasoline which is driven
by um uh by oil is um
uh three dollars and uh three dollars
and 31 cents it's not quite a double so
uh these are crazy policies uh we have
gone from the swing producer we have
gone from plentiful relatively cheap oil
and natural gas natural gas is the
really the beauty of it all uh clean
burning relatively clean burning
we're no longer the cheat they're not
investing our guys aren't producing now
there was a story in the paper saturday
morning
that joe biden
has rediscovered frackers okay someone
must have told him
that we can produce oil in the u.s so he
doesn't have to go to saudi arabia
hadn't hand or russia for european
national guess someone probably told him
whether it was they told him directly or
through a memo i can't verify that i've
been out of the white house for quite a
while but
maybe he's now going to go to our oil
companies and natural gas and say go
ahead produce because high prices are
damaging the middle class high price
prices are part of the problem of rising
inflation maybe i don't know that this
is going to happen i'm just saying that
was the headline
very interesting you know what i love
that you laid it out so clearly larry
the thing that i always remember when
you were in the white house and you
talked about the economic situation and
all those pro-growth policies the thing
i always noticed was that you always put
energy in there ending the war on energy
you always said it and because you
understand that it's the foundation it's
not some separate part of economic
policy it's the foundation of of a great
successful economy and you made it
happen when you were there and like with
everything else there they've gone into
reverse and it's a disaster anyway i'm
we're going to leave it there
it was all right
go on quickly no come on no i was going
to say it's a national security issue
and it's an economic issue yes exactly
one other positive thing here
joe manchin i think is forcing biden to
take out a big chunk of the green new
deal in this crazy budget resolution i i
think he's going to win that battle and
there's a revolt so at some point i
think we're going to go back to being
the swing producer but the more biden
fights this and the more the crazies on
the left fight it the worse american
economy is going to be and the worse our
national security position is going to
be
exactly right i'm glad i'm glad i'll let
you get that in there very important
point um both on the national security
front and on joe manchin larry as always
fantastic to see you i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kill me and i'm ainsley earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis